الالتزام روح المبادره وتنظيم الوقت دول
الثلاث كلمات اللي بحسهم سبب في اي نجاح
انا بقدر اوصل له انا اميره الجوهري 29
سنه مصممه برامج تدريبيه زوجه وام لطفله
اسمها عاليه
[موسيقى]
من وانا في كليه صيدله اما بدات احس ان
انا مش ده المجال المناسب لي اول المناسب
لطموحي شغفي وفي مره من المرات وانا
بتناقش مع بعض زمايلي عن طرق تدريس
المختلفه ومدى نجاحها او فشلها ان هي تحقق
هدفها حسيت ان انا ممكن ابقى لي دور ان
انا اصلح الموضوع ده ومن وقتها من وانا في
ثالثه جامعه بدات ادور على انشطه تطوعيه
لها علاقه بالتدريب والتدريس سواء لطلبه
زي في الجامعه او الشباب اصغر مني في
المدارس وبالفعل تطوعت في اكثر من نشاط
ليهم الهدف ده بعد ما تخرجت بدات اشتغل في
اكتر من شغلانه لها علاقه بالتدريس فمثلا
اشتغلت كمدرسه رياضه اطفال مدارس اللغه
الانجليزيه مدرسه
للكبار بعلمهم برده اللغه الانجليزيه ومن
وقتها بدات تشتغل على تحديد تحضير وترتيب
الماده التعليميه اللي انا بقدمها فحسيت
ان انا عندي شغل في تحضير المواد
التدريبيه دي ووقتها ما كنتش اعرف ان ده
مجال مختص بذاته
وتمر السنين واشتغل في اكثر من مشروع ليها
علاقه بالتعليم والتطوير سواء مثلا تعليم
الاطفال بالفن او اداره الوقت بالنسبه
للمراهقين وانشطه تانيه اداره يتعلموها
خلال الاجازه الصيفيه لقيت ان في ظهر مجال
اسمه تحضير او تطوير المواد التدريبيه او
الاستراكشن الميزان سنه 2020 وقت الكرونه
بالفعل اشتغلت كام مصممه برامج تدريبيه
ولقيت ان ده شغفي وان دي اكثر حاجه باقدر
اشتغل فيها واطلع فيها طاقتي وابداعي ومن
وقتها بدات اشوف ايه اللي اقدر اتعلمه
اكتر عن المجال ده
فقدمت فيه منحه عبد الله الغرير ودلوقتي
حاليا باعمل درجه ماجستير في اريزونا
يونيفرستي في امريكا همم خاصه بين ليرننج
ديزا او تكنولوجيا التعليم
كل التحديات اللي انا كنت بواجهها كانت
دايما بلاقيها من استغراب المجتمع واسرتي
ان ازاي حد يبقى معي كليه زي صيدله ويبدا
يشتغل او يدور على مجال ثاني
مختلف تماما فده شويه كان بيمثل لي نقطه
نقاش او صراع في حياتي بس في نفس الوقت
لما كان دايما اا بشتغل في اماكن مختلفه
كانوا بالنسبه لهم دي نقطه تدل على
الابداع يعني اا طبعا ما كنتش هقدر اوصل
اللي انا فيه دلوقتي من غير دعم زوجي ومن
غير الاصرار والعزيمه اللي انا ذكرتهم في
الاول
جاهز واجهه التحدي في دور المراه عامه
والصراع ما بين دورها في البيت ودورها في
المجتمع ده باين اكثر وقت يعني بعد ما
اتجوزت وخلفت لان طبعا بيبقى في ترتيب
اولويات واعاده هيكله الحياه كلها فبيبقى
شويه تحدي قدامي ان انا اقدر اوزن بين
شخصيتك امراه عامله وشخصيتي في البيت
كزوجه وام فده مش بيجيء غير بتنظيم الوقت
وطبعا بدي اعمل مستمر من الاسره ان هم
يقدروا يقدروا هل الوقت ده انا مثلا
محتاجاه اكثر اركز في دراسه او اركز في
شغل همم الوقت اللي بعده هقدر اعوض اللي
انا قصرت فيه وهبدا اهتم اكتر بالبيت فهو
شويه زي المهرج اللي بيلعب باكثر من كوره
اا محتاج يركز مع كل كوره في كل ااه في كل
وقت انا حلمي ان انا اعمل مكان تدريس
الاطفال يكون بيعتمد على تنميه مواهبهم مش
مجرد مناهج محفوظه او بتعتمد على النظام
التعليق فده من احد احلامي يبقى مكان فيه
اا بيتعاملوا مع الطبيعه وفي نفس الوقت
بيتعلموا حاجات لها علاقه بمواهبهم واا في
محطهم
[موسيقى]